[Music]
alright let's shift a little bit to some
religions okay you are a Christian
conservative that's correct just that
phrase trigger is a certain amount of
people so first off what what is a
Christian conservative
yeah which always which always stuns me
so I do a lot of campus tour I'll tell
you a quick story a lot of campus tours
and I go through my litany of what I
call hard truths told by Charlie Kirk
and I'll say you know socialism is the
greatest killer of human in the last 100
years and I'll say free enterprises of
the greatest economic system ever and
then I'll say three words and it drives
them so crazy I say God is real and it's
like they just start shaking the left
they think they don't know how to handle
it and half the place loves it half the
place hates it I don't know why that's
so triggering so I'm a Christian first
and foremost I believe you know Jesus
Christ was the son of God and he came
down and we you know he died for all our
sins and we have a good documentation of
that and we could debate and discuss
that whatever but as a Christian I'm you
know I believe that you know we are
called to try to advance the kingdom of
God and the Ministry of Jesus Christ as
many people as possible and as
peacefully as possible obviously right
so that's how I try to live my own
personal life and make my own personal
decisions as a conservative I'd say let
me provide everything so I I don't see
you proselytizing religion though in the
public way I've heard you speak before
sure and I've never heard you push that
so I say it every so often when when
asked but I look at my speaking no
different than sometimes doing a job
right so a plumber electrician that is
not going to tell every person he turns
around the corner like hey have you
heard this Craig you know what I mean so
you have to you don't want to be too
offsetting and off-putting but I also
try to you know through my some of my
platforms you know talk about my
personal beliefs no matter how
triggering it might be to other people
and I'm like campus tours I try to you
know advance but of course I could
probably do a better job of it but with
that being said I would consider myself
more as a Conservatorium which I find to
be a new breed of you know ideology
which you and I talked about and some
people have already been labeling
themselves as such and I find no
contradiction between my Christian
worldview and my political philosophy in
fact I find great amount of you know
synchrony actually between what I find
would I believe theologically and what I
believe spiritually and religious
to also what I advocate for politically
which is essentially the non-aggression
principle and you know believing in
productive people and free societies
should be able to make your choices as
you see fit as long as you're not
harming someone else how did Christians
end up as so much of the but of what the
left hates because you can open up every
day another BuzzFeed article mocking
isn't it right Chris items and Mike and
HuffPo and the they all love the Bible
oh yeah them oh yeah it's nuts but how
did that happen well so I think what
happened is that Christian conservatives
fell for a trap that they really should
have rejected which is we might hold
these truths very near and dear to our
heart theologically and biblically and
spiritually and religiously but I think
where the line was crossed is in the 60s
and 70s and 80s where we tried to impose
those beliefs through government policy
where people then inherently have a
rejection to it similarly how people are
rejecting the left imposing their crazy
worldview upon us right I think that was
a big mistake because it created this
kind of counter-revolution which is I
don't want to have to live the way some
Christian and Alabama wants me to live
does that make sense so it's it's the
imposition of those values through
legislation and government which is
something I don't necessarily support
right so I try to always advocate for
everyone my political positions through
a secular worldview because that is the
vast majority of people and that's the
actual the government system that we
have all need to decided to create we do
have a separation of church and state
and we should support that with that
being said I can still have my own
personal opinions and my own personal
you know ways to go about changing
public policy but when we start to say
we should support this law because it's
the Christian thing to do that is I
think beginning that has turned people
off for the last 30 years what does it
say also about Christians that you know
we talked about gay marriage before that
there was a shift sure there actually
has been a shift now you're basically
arguing it's a political shift or
utilitarian yes you're just you're sort
of giving me just a realist argument
yeah but is that is there something else
going on there to where there is so
could be amazing tolerance to tolerance
and
yeah and here's the other problem with
Christians and me being a card-carrying
member of this community and I try my
hardest and I fail is and I'm around a
lot of these Christians and I sometimes
fall into it is this legalism right is
that I'm somehow better than you because
I'm a Christian and I really think
that's done such a disservice to the
Christian community especially the
Christian conservative community it's
this sanctimonious approach to lifestyle
that I find to be really off-putting to
a lot of non-believers and people say
well I don't want to be a Christian
because they're always going to talk
down to me or they're gonna make me live
by this set of beliefs so they think
they're better than I am it's a
number-one critique I get it's not that
oh I don't believe Jesus Christ is
actually the Son of God or I don't
believe the Bible you know those are
actually things I think that could be
ironed out it's more so like I've always
been talked down to her when I was a
young kid I was in Catholic school and
they gave me these 15 things I couldn't
do and because of that I rebelled and
rejected so I think this idea that
actually Jesus Christ advocated for
which is hey I dined with the tax
collectors I was best friends with the
prostitutes right like I never thought
that they were any better than the my
disciples right and I and of course I
don't live this out the best I should
but where Christians have gotten it
wrong is this fierce fire and brimstone
legalist thou shalt homosexual you know
like that's wrong man yeah that's not
that's not what the the teachings and
the evidence we have of Jesus Christ
life ever taught us he was welcoming he
was tolerant he was accepting he had
standards he was fierce when it came to
eternity in the standards of God but he
wasn't afraid to go chill with tax
collectors which were considered like
the lowest form of individual possible
in the Middle East during that time
right and so I think we as Christians
can learn a lot of that in modern
societies and when we wrap this thing up
you want to go have lunch with some
prostitutes I mean if they want to hear
about the good news of Jesus Christ but
even so right he's sometimes some people
are like oh you know but the point being
is we should we as Christians have to do
a better job of not being the
sanctimonious moral conjectures which we
get labeled at summit and so much so
when you see a guy like Shapiro or a guy
like Prager preggers more than my heroes
I love them Prager basically a secular
view at this point but grew up wertha
Docs Shapiro obviously is
observant religious there have been
Orthodox Jew you guys basically from
what I can tell agree on pretty much
everything politically you're obviously
more Trump than than Shapiro is pretty
fine on any given day Prager definitely
is more proton but this does any of your
religious differences does I know that
doesn't matter to you in terms of
poverty that's very obvious but just in
terms of like your humanity or the way
your worldview does any of that matter
here you know I've had wonderful
discussions of Dennis Prager about what
he believes theological II and I mean
look first of all I think Dennis Prager
is like the Yoda of the conservative
movement he's like unbelievably
brilliant told you isn't it I know
exactly he's he's fantastic and same
with Ben I mean I listen to their stuff
every single day and Prager University
does a heroic job but it doesn't bother
me at all but I always challenge right
so I I challenge you know religious and
observant Jews with some pretty good you
know questions I think cuz I'm very big
in the apologetics of the New Testament
and the Christian you know the evidence
for you know Christianity I ask
questions I'll say do you believe Paul
existed in you know II think Paul Osiris
existed and they'll say yes I'll say
doesn't don't you think it's kind of
like weird that a Roman Jew dropped this
whole amazing lifestyle and like went
all-in for this Jesus Christ thing and
then got persecuted put in jail six
times and then reverse crucified like
would someone do that if they actually
didn't believe this that's a provocative
question obviously right but I love that
and I love that kind of you know
discussion and look Paul said very
clearly in the New Testament bless the
Jews you know these are your brothers
there is no New Testament out the Old
Testament so we agree you know with the
Jewish people and all that and look I
think we need more Jews to actually
become more observant and to understand
the roots of the Torah and the roots of
what God commanded through Moses and
through David and the the major and
minor prophets and I have such great
respect for them because they've done a
great job of I think awakening people
that there are you know Jewish
conservatives out there and it's okay to
believe these things well it's
interesting because there's someone that
doesn't come from this from a religious
perspective I agree with the wider
principle that you're pushing here which
is that some of these minority
communities so in this case you're
talking about Jews but you reference
black people earlier which I want to
talk a little short that working with
Candace
but now I see it within the Asian
community I don't know if you just saw
in the last couple of days there's this
email that got leaked from Google where
they're basically were saying we're
gonna hire people but not white men or
Asian women will be treated like white
women or something something to that
horribly racist it's it's the real
reason it's real racism though yeah it's
this kind of like it's just there's this
ranking of oppression Olympics like
somehow your skin color makes you
somewhat more you know worthy of a
position and a company or in a
university because you've been through
more just because you look different or
the scary part especially for the asian
community is that your skin color and
the way you look is makes you less
worthy because you're gonna work real
hard and you're gonna have the right
decisions on the right decision i mean
make no mistake it's like an anti asian
american worldview that the left is now
essentially embraced it's like oh
they've been successful enough now we
must discriminate against them so we can
help the it's like it's it's it's it's
lunacy but going back to your point of
the christian conservative kind of
worldview i think there's a lot there's
a lot of us that hold these beliefs very
personal but also that's that's kind of
where we draw the line is you know we
have these personal beliefs and they're
gonna dictate how we want to live
individually but how do we advocate for
a society that allows the most amount of
people to advocate for their own
personal beliefs whatever they might be
as long as it doesn't harm someone else
so your basic argument i think you hit
on this a little bit earlier would be
that the part of the reason that europe
is crumbling which it is crumbling what
the West is crumbling except for America
yeah I mean we're so we're taping this
it's gonna go up next week but we're
taping this today is the three year
anniversary of well Charlie Hebdo was a
couple of years ago three years but
today was the day that they finally
caught the guy and then there was the
shooting at the kosher supermarket in
Somers and all that today a different
supermarket was burned down I mean this
is this is still happening in Paris
right now and this is happening all
across Europe we know what's going on in
Sweden all those your basic premise
would be that if they had held on to
some of their judeo-christian values
instead of trading them in for what what
do you think secularism essentially
statism right like you but yet you're
also a secularist which is an interest
well no but no I don't think it's not I
don't think it's contradictory because I
would make an argument
that actually the separation of church
and state found in America has helped
the church we still have the highest
church-going grades rates in the West we
still the highest levels of private
philanthropy have more churches opening
than ever before the evangelical
community is growing in most states as
Alan Dershowitz would say the separation
of church and state has been the best
thing for the church because it's not
imposed upon people it's not mandatory
as you and I both agree when as soon as
you start to tell someone to do
something it becomes a lot less sexy and
appealing yeah it actually want to rebel
against that you want to reject it I
would argue Europe through their social
welfare programs have deteriorated the
church as soon as they start to say
government is gonna take care of people
government is going to be the most
important thing in your life
government's gonna fix these vastly
complex social problems then all of a
sudden the church and the individual
becomes far less significant as Dennis
Prager says the larger the government
the smaller the citizen you're seeing
that play out in France and Spain and
Portugal and Italy where you have
individual philanthropy disappear where
you have business startups neccessity
totally evaporate and the final point is
what it really lends itself to is more
dangerous ideologies to take forms such
as radical Islam which is I think one of
the most dangerous widespread
ideological movements happening the West
that no one is talking about and here's
I can understand I mean you're a gay guy
I mean I would probably be worried if I
start to see you know radical Islam
start to take root in Europe right
you're a Christian I'd be worried too no
I mean trust me I'm on that program okay
they want us both dead my friend Yeah
right
I mean they and that's something I find
to be horribly inconsistent with the
left is they try to be the champions of
all these minority groups and all these
supposed to depress groups yet here they
are kind of joining forces with
countries and movements and you know
theocratic fascists in the Middle East
that give homosexuals flying lessons on
the top of buildings all right so then
how do we I spend I think a good chunk
especially the first year of this show
trying to talk about radical Islam
making a distinction between radical
Islam and the nominal Muslim person who
practices their faith privately however
they do just like most sure people I try
to separate Islam as a set of ideas
worthy of criticism as Christianity is
and you
service and republicanism and all of
that okay
versus people versus criticizing people
and treating people differently I think
a lot of people in our space have tried
to do that and you don't get a lot of
credit for it but okay fine I don't I
don't need bonus credit but how how do
we talk about radical Islam well in an
honest way and I do there is a
differentiation that needs to be drawn
but it also we also do need to talk
about the broader implementation of an
is of an Islamic government and
worldview
right so Islam as its core at its core
has always been and will always be tied
into the state and as soon as they can
demonstrate that they can be a majority
in a country and not be a theocratic
government then I'll start to cede some
territory against that so for example
Saudi Arabia right so if you are
Christian and Saudi Arabia you lose your
head if you're a Jew they'll find your
family and kill all of you that's
there's something wrong about that right
so I think we need to draw a great
critique of that same in a land which is
Shia and Saudi which is Sunni and
there's something really I think not
correct about in modern society that you
have obviously a Muslim majority country
and you know there's no Christians and
no Jews and no churches and no
synagogues there's something very
intolerant about that however people
that want to reform Islam I'm your
biggest advocates right people that want
to go through a reformation of you know
Islam and try to differentiate that know
Islam does not have to be tied to the
state and yes Islam can be tolerant of
Christians and Jews and gays and the
modern feminist movement and they should
be allowed to vote and drive and you
know be able to make decisions as they
see fit and not have to wear a full
hijab
I want those Muslims that succeed I'm
frightened that the more radical voices
which are in the tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions are actually
getting more more of an audience they're
they're they're creating you know
sectors of Europe that are quite
troubling that are advocating for the
advancement of these more dangerous
ideologies that support honor killings
and don't think women should have the
right to drive or to vote or to be able
to have representation in any sort of
form of government and so I think a
broader critique of Islam needs to be
put forth because they've been doing it
against Christianity for the last 100
years I walk into a lecture hall and I
hear about how important
and Christians are and how they're
terrible people find hard stop you go to
the Vatican a woman is allowed to wear
shorts and you know a cut-off t-shirt
you go to Mecca and you're a Christian
you get your head cut off I mean you
literally can't go no you literally are
not allowed they're literally not a lot
so there there's there's a discussion
that needs to happen where a broader
Reformation is necessary but the more
radical voices of Islam are actually
succeeding right now
you look at the most viral members of
the YouTube community in the Sunni you
know Saudi region though they're the
ones that are advocating for a holy war
and the extermination of Christians
they're the ones that are really taking
root we have to support we have to
reinforce and we have to really
encourage the more reformist muslims to
get a broader you know platform but i'm
just not seeing it yeah i mean i've
tried to do a little bit of it you know
you've done a good job help some
reformers and some x muslims and things
like that but the problem is that
they're constantly undercut by their own
people e their own people yeah every
times one of them talks about this they
say you're a sellout or you're sure
people or but it does beg the question
and like that that the center of their
faith is the most intolerant city in the
world someone's got to take a broad
stand against that and maybe we'll see
it in the next hundred years but commet
been saman you know the new Crown Prince
of Saudi Arabia is trying to do some
more you know modern changes but you're
also seeing extraordinary radical voices
in Saudi Arabia continually rise up
you're seeing protests in Iran which is
great but then you're seeing a lot of
the Western world not stand with these
protests or see president Trump is done
a great job with it Obama who is totally
silent
so look Islam in general there's there's
wonderful Muslim friends that I have and
productive members of the American
community that embrace this idea that
you can hold your beliefs without having
to have them push through a state which
is is great but you're also seeing the
exact opposite with them you know the
Muslim Brotherhood taking further route
in Egypt and in Turkey you're seeing you
know Saudi Arabia want to continue its
influence throughout the Arabian
Peninsula it's gonna be a conflict of
ideas and it's the largest religion I
believe in the world correct me if I'm
wrong 1.2 billion people Christianity's
right up against but I would argue that
Islam has a lot more power in countries
and Christianity does the Reformation
that needs to happen so is the
demographic time bomb in in Europe is it
already too late
it's troubling away it's very troubling
so as a byproduct of supporting social
welfare programs in the 60s and 70s that
deteriorated the influence of the
Catholic Church and in Protestantism
throughout Europe and really just kind
of making people so apathetic towards
private philanthropy apathetic towards
value creation entrepreneurship rates
disappeared and you really created a
lazy european society hate to say it but
they are not highly productive people
they take the month of August off they
have very little ambition they're okay
being average that's not the society I
want to live in America has always been
aspirational we've been the most
productive we've been the risk takers
we've been we've been the entrepreneurs
so because of that they've laid
themselves to be remarkably vulnerable
to a takeover culturally and
demographically and you're starting to
see that with the millions of
relocations from the middle east of
people that don't hold these views that
the Europeans hold then honestly they
come from a background whether it be
Syria or Jordan
or Yemen or Oman Yemen there's a huge
humanitarian crisis happening they've
known nothing but government being
Islamic and so they inherently support
that but if they want to go through the
Reformation and they can demonstrate
they can do that great I'm not seeing
that though I'm seeing vast demographic
clashes happening all throughout Europe
there's also an interesting generational
piece to this which is that you find
that a lot of the older people that came
from those countries you know 30 years
ago they actually are more westernized
and they're torturing are now they're
sort of making up that there was
something imaginarily great about Saddam
that's correct or their parents we need
that we need to reform the cat-lair you
rebuild the caliphate and very dangerous
right and so you look at the Reformation
that Christianity right rightfully went
through in the 1500s and 1600s and 1700s
it's as soon as you embrace the idea of
personal freedom and individual liberty
and you try to restrict the state so put
your put yourself in the in the in the
seat of the founding fathers they
intentionally removed any sort of
mention of Christendom in the
Constitution which end up being the best
thing for Christianity which created the
most Christian nation in the world which
is America think about how ironic that
is right whereas Europe then always do
that they actually created these
theocratic governments that led way to
you know horrible conflict and you know
ethno-nationalism and eventually in the
sixties and seventies like I mentioned
the huge proliferation of the welfare
state which was the worst decision
Europe ever made they turned a highly
productive people into a mediocre lazy
society that rejected all sorts of
religion and any sort of you know
connection to higher being and has now
led themselves to a demographic takeover
that I think is there were some people
think it's for the better I just don't
see any evidence of that right again
there's nothing--there's and I I get I
get criticized as being a racist and all
this I'm not I'm talking about a set of
ideas that when implemented through the
state have proven to be extremely
dangerous to human rights and economic
productivity and private property rights
and really human you know human dignity
so when you've mentioned the phrase
oppression Olympics a couple of times
which obviously I totally buy in on
which is from your video I stole it from
you but well I think I stole it from
Faisal Saitama ptarth and he probably
stole it from somebody so that's how
these ideas get around but this idea of
this this intersectional nonsense which
is all nonsense the how do you do you
think that the average left person in
America that you know says they're a
feminist and therefore what do you think
that they don't recognize any of the
stuff that you just said about obviously
don't talk about it but they might they
might they might recognize it they might
know about it they might be able to
answer in a Trivial Pursuit game but the
question is here so you're there's the
international feminist society which is
growing huge on campus and I always
challenge them they advocate for women's
rights across the world and then they're
like right next to like the Muslim
Student Association which is fine they
should be friends that's okay but why
are they not demonstrating wide-set
widespread protests against how women
are treated in Saudi Arabia but the
international feminist society is
protesting for against Israel yeah it's
weird right it's like because
intersectionality it's like they have
this weird construct that we must
advocate against Israel because Israel's
a friend of America and America hates
women it's like this weird like I need
like this big map like where they kind
of try it doesn't make any sense but
where is the outrage they say there's
outrage when I challenge them oh yeah
we're really outraged about it yeah okay
sure but no where's the where's the
where's the Oprah Winfrey's right
where's the Hillary Clinton's who spoke
multiple times and Saudi Arabian took
millions of dollars from now right where
women can't drive where women care now
they can drive that's going to be a
disaster you know no it is because all
of a sudden they're just wait for the
moms to get your hands and hands up
there women are in what do you mean oh
because they're gonna have a total
religious clash about this because the
hum had been some on say it's said by
decree that women can drive and there's
going to be all these religious
fundamentalists that are not gonna allow
it to happen and it's gonna be a total
conflict they were bragging that women
are allowed to go to movies now like
that to show you how medieval Saudi
Arabia's right
but anyway Hillary Clinton made this
like her pinnacle you know point of her
campaign is like I'm gonna really have
good relations with Saudi Arabia her
foundation took tens of millions of
dollars here was a woman that ran on the
idea of like feminist representation
right and she can't critique Saudi
Arabia once right but she critiques
Israel for the settlements right so I
think there's unbelievable hypocrisy
there but it's not just Saudi Arabia
which I'm focusing its Egypt
it's a ran it's Iraq which is changing
its Syria its Jordan it's online it's
Yemen the only countries that get it
right or Qatar right and maybe the UAE
but you have you have a geographic
disposition of hundreds of millions of
square miles where women cannot vote
women cannot own property women cannot
start businesses women cannot serve in
governments men have total and absolute
control over society gays they asked
akka FEMA job they said how do you how
do you treat have no yeah how do you
treat gays in your society we do not
have all the sex rules in our country
that's great where's the where's the
LGBT international society protesting
against that right now it's like they
have this kind of like handshake like
we're not gonna mention this it's all
good
that can't stand anymore right and then
what what country did I hate the most of
course its Israel where we're days are
open you know are openly productive
members of society I think they can
marry in Israel not sure but I the West
has been the best to women and to gays
and yet they want to destroy the West
which doesn't make any sense to me
by the way you mentioned settlements a
minute ago I think that Jesus got you
reference before I lived in a town
called Bethlehem and where he was born
in that lands in the West yeah exactly
Jesus of Nazareth yeah minor details
here right yeah but history though is
just lost on people right is that like
to me that's one of the most oh it's all
things like it's just that people don't
know basics about history well it even
it's it's the basics but it's just like
the
ignorant of understanding the the the
blessings we have the live in Western
civilization and how unique what we
really have here is a country and it's
being taught in our universities how
America's a racist xenophobic
imperialist horrible country and you
really have to try it takes effort to
try to make that argument because
America has been one of the greatest if
not one of the greatest ideas ever
implemented in human history and civil
society it's had more respect for human
rights it's had more economic
productivity we have freed more people
from serfdom and from bondage and any
other country we voluntarily sent our
citizens and our civilians and our
soldiers to die for the freedoms of
others without asking for anything in
return you look at the Korean War we
send you know our boys from Iowa Kansas
South Carolina and Florida to go die in
the Korean Peninsula 50,000 of them so
that South Korea can exist we asked for
nothing in return if we were imperialist
where the worst imperialist ever right
and so yet it takes the effort to really
look at look at history and say that
we're a horrible place and this is what
the modern American Left is trying to do
is like remember when I send the
beginning of the video we have a choice
we can either go the way of Europe and
totally fundamentally transform this
country and embrace a set of ideas we've
never had or we can defend respect and
advance American ideas here and really
try to make the 21st century the
greatest we've ever had is there an
inherent risk in some of that though
that yes there are things like South
Korea that work out there's always on
foreign policy yeah I mean there's a lot
of instances we've had ones blunders I
mean Iraq war was a total mistake yeah
it was a disaster so they so there
that's just the inherent risk in this
space I don't know that was sanctioned
by the way by Congress in the Senate and
sure the United wasn't it wasn't
actually an effective odd war of
authorization was a conflict but so what
I meant there is a broader point that
throughout the 20th century America has
stepped up and fought for the freedom
and liberty of others not ever asking
for something returned I would argue
that Iraq was it was a horrible response
the 9/11 had nothing to do with the
actual existential threats against the
homeland that was george w bush trying
to rectify a mistake that his father
didn't actually make which was take over
you know saddam hussein's empire we got
next to nothing we lost 30,000 american
troops we spent two trillion dollars we
didn't have and we helped create Isis to
boot
so imposing American ideas worldwide is
not something that I would have ever
advocate for but argue but when when the
chips are down for example you know in
World War two and you know the Nazi
Empire is on the March and they're
sixteen miles away from Moscow and you
know Winston Churchill is on his hands
and knees begging FDR to send troops
then we send you know half a million
ground troops to go through Normandy we
stepped up right and we helped push back
European fascism so look there's been a
lot of mistakes some of our incursions
in Central America were total disasters
but net-positive Americas you know
decisions throughout the 20th century
have helped you know advance human
freedom and and release people from
bondage so to that end you must love
what Trump's doing with the UN right
what's that are you
Haley it's a freaking all-star here's
all about nikki Haley and to my left is
people watching this yeah how can you
not recognize she's everything you
pretend to advocate for no no Sarah
because she's a son daughter of an
immigrant she's a minority you know and
she's Indian I mean like from actual
India right which is one of their I
think oppression Olympics groups what
you saw this thing like a couple weeks
ago where they were trying to mock her
for using the name Nikki and it's like
that's what her parents called I know
managin if a Republican said that their
Margaret
she's totally self-made her father
literally owned convenience stores
started at a state senator ran as an
insurgent for governor twice elected
eradicated the Confederate flag from her
State Capitol balanced the budget
created South Carolina into this
unbelievably prosperous state in a very
complicated political state by the way
by the way they always said you know the
south is so racist well they yell twice
elected you know a woman minority
governor of a state that you call you
know the new you know Confederacy anyway
what about that Tim Scott guy exactly
one of the only there's only two
african-american senators and one of
them's from what they call one of the
most racist states in the country that's
aside the point then should get selected
by President Trump who supposedly hates
women but he hasn't represent us in the
UN to go fiercely fight against all
these globalist forces at the UN cuts
aid to the Pakistan she is what the left
is supposed to love right
she is the she is this absolute
embodiment of modern-day feminism yeah
they hate her did you see this tweet the
other day by the at Democrats you know
the official oh yeah well
the check marks yeah women product
qualified woman but the bet well that of
course that's that's like the blankie
response but the best was leaked so it
was like you know do you minority women
brown women but a the amount of people
who dress rub it all right you're
endorsing nikki Haley and it's like man
you guys this is what you idiots have
created that's right there and I can't
tell you it's really interesting because
so many of our turning point members and
our turning point students I say why are
you conservative I'm a student I'm not
considered because of the left I left
the left because of the left because
they have lost their freaking mind like
if they were just like normal Democrats
and didn't say the stupid stuff and of
intersectionality politics and like they
argue that well we can run government
better but free enterprise is a good
thing but flawed we need a per we need
to get perfect it and you know if they
actually had some humility for it
instead of just like embracing cultural
Marxism and doing the oppression
Olympics I think you might still be on
the left instead they've created the
greatest gift thank you liberals for
doing this leftist because now we have
like former Bernie Sanders supporters
running our chapters because they are
now cultural Marxist that looked at
people how to call their skin by how
much value they have in the world or how
great you can understand someone's you
know that you know degree of suffering
which is everything that Martin Luther
King argued against which is everything
that has fundamentally created this
country and so thank you leftist for
helping create this movement for us are
there any good Democrats left oh sure
there I've my issues with plenty of
Republicans and I'd be more of a Rand
Paul Republican and a libertarian board
yeah do you want to join the I call them
ass if evil empire you could join the
resist the real resist there's the real
or is it since I mean look the stuff
that I like about Rand and Paul
obviously is all the libertarians of
course
sadly in that collection of eighteen
people that were running against Trump
he was seemingly on the wrong stage it
just the party had nothing to do with
yeah bad time what he wanted even if as
you've said before Trump may be doing a
lot of things those things right now
would show you a sure plexus hole very
compliant but look the question I think
you had was but the new general any good
Democrats is there anyone I'm still
looking for that kind of like Blue Dog
Democrat to rise up and be like you know
I'm a Democrat that is pro-choice which
I disagree with whatever that is you
know all these things but I still think
America's
country and we need to like rid our our
country of an sefa alan dershowitz is
probably only one I could think of right
now whose bill the way he's getting
kicked out of the Democrat Party
everybody abuse he's taking I'm saying
this every week since when is it since
when has it been a bad thing to be Alan
Dershowitz I mean the guy is freaking
brilliant like you might disagree with
him but he's like the smartest lean a
lawyer and human rights attorney that
you could possibly find and now the
Democrats been like music she's being
paid by the Trump campaign like are you
kidding me yeah I mean he's brilliant
and they're kicking him up yeah I love
that mitt so yeah there are some good
Democrats out there Charlie I suspect we
could do this for a couple more hours
but if you want to I'm only gonna ask
you one more because I want this on the
record on this show but when it happens
it should be that I asked at first
you're gonna run for so no no no not for
political office I want to I want to be
a be a commentator in a movement driver
does that have anything to do with the
clown show that that running is that a
guy like you who you obviously have a
great understanding of the issues you
have a consistent line of thought
whether I agree with you and every far
too principal no but there's something
to be said for that I think so I mean
that goes to what coworker said about
his broker right I think but but in all
reality I love what I got to do
seriously like every day I get to create
a movement and help facilitate a movie
not create well and say what I want to
say and be able to you know have
conversations to you on all this stuff
I've met very few Congress people are
senators or governors that actually
enjoy what they do seriously and it's
always about meeting with lobbyists or
cow telling the leadership and
fundraising it just makes me sick to my
stomach thinking about that but let's
pretend it was a great gig which some of
them seem to like it
I don't know why they like the
corruption or something I like is that
really a place where I can do the most
amount of good for my worldview and I
would say probably not no I'd say look
turning points doing a great service for
the country I think right now I love
what I get to do I've you know have some
influence in helping shape this policy
in this agenda and that doesn't seem
like fun to me it doesn't seem like that
would maximize my amount of happiness
yeah alright why it's on the record now
it's on the record I talk like a
politician
I think we're doing a gig together in
New Hampshire yeah I'll be fine not too
long from now so when we get in Tanis
I'll be there too and Candice Owens will
be quick yeah sure let's just finish
talking to Canada about Candice for a
moment so when I when I met you that day
I referenced that literally a minute
before you had I saw it from a distance
you and Candice talked for about two
minutes and then she walked over to me
and she's like I just got a job with
turning-point Charlie wants me to you
know help talk to the black community in
blah blah blah
she's quickly becoming an all-star in
this space I think she escaped some of
the YouTube madness which I'm somewhat
aware of and you may have seen my insane
debate with her and Blair white and blah
blah blah but she's quickly becoming a
real power household along house because
the black community has needed more
people the Thomas Souls and Larry elders
and David Webb's and who have Allen West
whoever out there it's a different
generation she's coming at it from the
front young place it's kind of beautiful
she's unbelievably talented
I've spent a considerable amount of time
with her now - the five minutes I hire
but she's a passionate driven person
look broader than that she like like all
of us on our team believe and understand
there is a movement happening in this
country and it's something the media
will not report it's something palpable
when you experience it you saw it in
Florida there's something happening in
this everything crazy and it's it's
almost quasi spiritual political it's so
there's something happening because the
left has tried for far too long to
suppress the movement of ideas and free
speech and dialogue and discussion but
what Candice believes which I'm in full
support of and I want to help her in
every way possible is that the
african-american community has been
totally dis served for lack of a better
term by the modern Democratic Party and
that they are disproportionately more
poor they're disproportionately in worse
circumstances than people of every other
you know ethnic racial group but why is
that it's not because America is a more
racist country than we were in the 1960s
in fact no one with a straight face
could possibly say that yet
african-americans are poor today than
they were in the 1960s so what happened
to use a Hillary Clinton term America
did not get more racist
America got significantly less racist
there's still racism in this country but
a lot of it has been eradicated if not
reversed it what happened is that we as
Americans supported one of the
you know I would say contentious
political and social programs which was
the great society where we D incentivize
the black community from making good
choices we incentivize women to say
single and have babies we destroyed
public sector education by reinforcing
the public sector teacher unions and
disallowing school choice and rewarding
bad teachers and keeping communities
perpetually poor we I think really did a
disservice by have you starting this war
on police in the last couple years which
most police officers are there for the
betterment of the communities that they
police and we have started this
narrative that America is somehow an
inherently racist country and African
Americans are poor because of a racist
country the data does not reflect that
it's because we have created a set of
government policies and ideas that have
not incentivized African Americans to
continually make good choices that break
out of poverty and as Ben Shapiro says
you make these three choices you get
married before you have kids you
graduate high school and you get a job
you can break out of poverty in this
country and we you can look to all three
of those things we have government
programs that either discourage or D
incentivize every one of those choices
especially for African American
community and at Candis growing up from
the poor family going up as a you know
african-american woman in this culture
in the society can talk about a lot
better than I can I can only talk about
it from an outsider
she's an insider which in today's time
unfortunately buys you a lot more
institutional credibility which it
really shouldn't right I mean that's the
irony it's it's it's sort of using
identity politics against itself what
you almost have to what you almost have
to do because if for Xavier prize is the
greatest way to solve poverty and canvas
says it it doesn't make it any more or
less or true just because she's a black
woman right truth is truth no matter who
says it but the left somehow has a value
you know a lot higher if certain people
saying it but you know what if identity
politics is what we have to play then so
be it and Candis understands that
especially on college campuses black
students will listen to her a lot more
likely than they'll listen to me and I
believe that she can continually build a
movement around these core set of ideas
and values and principles and she gets
it cuz she used to be one of them she
used to be a leftist she understands who
these people are and she understands how
to fight them and how to persuade and
we're lucky to have her as our director
of urban engagement at Turning Point USA
I know you
like drug references but when I had her
on I said you know for me it was like
the red pill was like I was like slowly
drinking it like tea
she said she snorted it all the power to
hurt as long as I didn't harm someone
else do whatever you want to do with
your life I wanted to end me in with you
in a slightly awkward position here we
go none of your employees that there we
go that seemed very good well listen
you're doing great stuff I'm thinking
forward to to getting out on the road
with you and well you're doing a lot
also you don't know mouth hurt at the
end of that week because you're smiling
so much
I literally at one point I could not
smile anymore I can't it were not
students just great I mean they were
just and by the way speaking of standing
ovations I mean Candice got a massive
massive ovation everyone got a scent I
mean I here's I think that's the
diversity of ideas is we will give a
standing ovation of people even if we
don't agree with what they have to say
completely right and that's the left
won't do that it's like get out of my
room get out of mice get out of our you
know lecture hall and it's a movement
around true tolerance and true
discussion of ideas and we're gonna win
all right well to find out more about
Charlie's 2028 campaign for presidency
follow him on the twitter at charlie
kirk 11:00
[Music]
you